o raio do sol
[Música]
eis o que os ossos ea ua
eu volto já
box e do próximo e zaire esconder vários
mas depois aprendi que a gente precisa
pensar eu vou compartilhar a aceitar
essa história toda a história da minha
história em oito capítulos só pessoa que
olha pra pessoas já feira pessoas como
eu que já pensa diferente sem nota
mas não foi fácil nunca é fácil
eu estou dizendo que você se depara com
uma situação diferente precisão na hora
fazer milhares de pessoas quiseram
a frente é a maior onda que repassou uma
boate de jovens a cf que a esaf chegando
é hora de vocês falou não espera outra
pessoa eu vou mostrar agora porque houve
nada
eu sempre vivi sempre quando existe
algum dia se vai
quando você está lá para vocês é o outro
e entende que o outro lado de serra
a comunicação foi o primeiro realizado a
segunda pessoa não goste do meu bairro é
absurdo escolher o dia 3 quando chegava
de carro
e aqui nada é igual o que anima o evento
foi feito com a editora
eu não entendia o do dava certo
organizar é e pegava dinheiro também
seria que se fala todo sete de seus
valores passa a mãe que é quando você
pega as coisas você quer
o upgrade segurei o braço e busquei
ambiental
ele tem o meu grande professor de
negócios que nem a nokia irá visitar a
seleção de final de 2001 aquele momento
[Música]
[Aplausos]
que chamou de el show realmente entende
que é você fazer
o fato de você não infectados com os
fatos mas o que deve e tem como foco
[Aplausos]
principal a outra pessoa o que acontece
com você é alguém susto nada fácil você
está fazendo
em uma bola frente a uma igreja
todos na expectativa que eu ia fazer
essa circular com nada
[Aplausos]
ele descobriu uma bola melhor preço
mínimo
[Aplausos]
[Música]
o cliente ou ó
quando você está presente você der certo
as coisas vão surgir
você está para mim você percebe que
levaram o cds é coordenado pela pide
fica fora podendo e poderia aprender a
fazer o pessoal até hoje é difícil
trabalhar
olha nós vamos fazer uma festa do pijama
abrigava 15
vou colocar o que fazer com a chamada em
todas as filhas
a gente tinha a minha filha ela não
pensa em chegar de qualquer perda de
dinheiro rodriguinho
[Aplausos]
o filme ela ganha tempo gasta em jogos
fora
[Música]
eu venho aqui é um lindo anel
hoje cinco anos onze vezes sorriu
existe uma marcação ó incidir em são
paulo
então surgiu o convite favor não me
importo quando você sente à vontade
op você está fazendo
imagina você insiste que não sabia que
se tratava de uma peça retrata gente em
si é diferente nem sei qual a isso em
posicionar para a china começou a surgir
israel a mãe já estava indo embora
daniel vega e até abaixo eu falei ai
olha olha como assim eu comecei uma
briga
como assim
disso eu tenho certeza de vida e eu
tenho um cachorro que vai fazer em seis
vezes
qualquer forma é preciso muita atenção
você tem que trabalhar a energia mental
entendia física dele precisa até um
pouco você tem acontecido naquele
momento em que o pai de família também é
pop rock mas eu não tenho seis meses de
vida eu tenho muito mais porque todos os
cachorros chamas ainda hoje
isso dá uma volta tal coisa symbol choro
e ensinou
[Música]
três agentes e um sempre leva rafaela
sim à tecnologia
eu falei pô eu vou pular em na qualidade
e inovação
eu vou para o conformismo ea
previsibilidade falou assim amor eu
confio em você e eu disse nossa eu só
precisava disso
você precisa ter alguém que diz eu
confio em você
não existe caminho certo e errado existe
alguém que acredita em você e que torce
por você e aí
com todas essas oito pessoas que
compartilhei com vocês para conquistar
resultados incríveis superando eu existe
uma ordem a primeira ordem é tem um
objetivo claro
a segunda é você planejar a sua vida que
seja no papel que seja no chão
a terceira coisa é você se conhecer a
quarta coisa vocês gerir o seu tempo a
quinta coisa é fazer a gestão desses
pontos fracos a sexta coisa é você se
comunicar direito a sétima é manter o
foco ea oitava coisa é você ter
indicadores de desempenho
na minha vida eu aprendi que se depende
sempre de tanta muito diferente gente
toda pessoa tem que sempre tem as marcas
das lições diárias de outras tantas
pessoas e é tão bonito quando a gente
entende que a gente é tanta gente onde
quer que a gente vá e é tão bonito
quando a gente entende que nunca está
sozinho por mais que pensa está
conquistando resultados incríveis
superando eu então obrigado
[Aplausos]